une arrivée à l'image de chacun des
chefs et derrière les civilités d'usagé
3 sommes conscients que ce débat sur
l'économie pourrait bien devenir un
point tournant de la campagne job c'est
l'emploi qui lance les hostilités
le chef conservateur at il un plan qui
va au delà de l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles
les premiers pas sont timides
stephen harper défend son bilan accusé
par thomas mulcair d'avoir tout misé sur
le pétrole
les discussions sur l'économie et
l'environnement offriront les premiers
échanges plus musclée chef conservateur
est la cible des attaques
il se défend d'avoir négligé
l'environnement mais soutient que le
secteur pétrolier a besoin de l'appui du
gouvernement
la forme du débat donne lieu à des
échanges souvent cacophonique
chaque chef tentant tant bien que mal de
faire porter son message
la crise des migrants s'invite dans le
débat quand on aborde de l'importance de
l'immigration pour l'économie canadienne
chef du npd accusent stephen harper
d'avoir compliqué le système
nous devons être plus ouverts l'an
justin trudeau au chef conservateur
rappelle sa promesse d'accueillir plus
de réfugiés d'accélérer le traitement de
leurs demandes mais opposant distille
voudrait que l'on ouvre nos frontières
sans se soucier de la sécurité fait
qu'entretenir l'accord
ripostera thomas mulcair si stephen
harper fut la cible de plusieurs
attaques
justin trudeau a également essuyé
quelques coups entre autres sur son
abandon de l'équilibré budgétaire mais
au bout du compte personne n'aura réussi
le grand coup qu'il souhaitait ce débat
maintenant terminée les trois chefs
reprennent la campagne dès demain en
route vers le premier débat francophone
la semaine prochaine à montréal
si daniel thibault radio canada